no objection i welcome them to our
subcommittee you'll be able to question
our witnesses if they are yielded time
by subcommittee members
finally would ask all members both those
in person and those appearing remotely
to mute your microphones
when you're not speaking this will help
prevent feedback other technical issues
and unmute yourself when you are
recognized
i'll now recognize myself for an opening
statement
while there's still many details to be
learned about tuesday's horrific
shootings in atlanta
that left eight people dead six of them
reportedly of asian descent
one thing is certain for many asian
americans tuesdays
shocking events felt like the inevitable
culmination of a year in which there
were nearly
3 800 reported incidents of anti-asian
hate incidents
that grew increasingly more violent over
time as the covet 19 pandemic worsened
and some people wrongly blamed asian
americans
or implied such by calling it the china
virus
these incidents include cases of verbal
harassment
being spat at slapped in the face
lit on fire slashed with a box cutter
or shove violently to the ground and
that number of reported incidents is
just likely the tip of the iceberg
i want to make clear that all asian
americans who are understandably feeling
hurt and afraid right now and wondering
whether anyone else in america
cares that congress sees you we stand
with you
will do everything in our power to
protect you
any asian hate did not begin with the
coven 19 pandemic and will not end when
the pandemic is over
all the pandemic did was exaggerate
latent anti-asian prejudices that have
long
long ugly history in america it's also
provided an excuse for some to act on
those prejudices
in fact there have been discrimination
against lots of people in this country
and all of that has been exaggerated but
the asian situation
has been the most
extreme pandemics wars geopolitical
tensions and
economic competition and the fear and
resentment that these situations create
have historically provided the
conditions for anti-asian racism and
xenophobia to take root
often leading to tragic consequences for
asian americans
for example social and economic
resentment against chinese labor in the
1800s led to the enactment of chinese
exclusion act of
1882 which barred nearly all immigration
from china
and the 1924 immigration act effectively
barred immigrant
immigration from all asian countries in
1942 the united states government
committed the most sweeping violation of
civil liberties in american history
other than slavery itself when it
ordered the forced internment of 120
000 japanese americans many of them
second and third generation americans
during the second world war based not on
any legitimate national security
concerns but on the racist and
xenophobic assumption that americans of
japanese ancestry
would be disloyal in 1982
chinese american vincent chen was beaten
to death by two white auto workers
because his
attackers thought he was japanese and
therefore responsible for the decline of
u.s
automobile industry on september 15
2001 balbir singh
sodhi a sikh gas station owner in
arizona was murdered by a man who blamed
him for the 911 terrorist attacks
to this list we now add the most recent
victims of anti-asian hate as asian
americans are wrongfully blamed for the
covenant 19 pandemic
while many of the recent anti-asian
incidents may not meet legal
definition of hate crime
these attacks nonetheless create an
unacceptable environment of fear and
terror in asian american communities
attacks like the one on 84 year old visa
ratana pakhti on january 28 of this year
was on a walk in his neighborhood he was
walking in his neighborhood was
violently slammed to the ground he died
a few days later from the brain trauma
that he sustained
i'd now like to play a video of that
attack caught by a nearby surveillance
camera
sadly this incident was one of several
recent ones that were elderly
asian americans were similarly knocked
violently to the ground
left unchecked racist attitudes stoked
by racist rhetoric
can have deadly consequences for
innocent people as we've just witnessed
in that
sad clip in such a time as the ones
we're living in is incumbent on all
elected
all public officials elected or
otherwise and public figures to speak
out against the
irrational hatreds and prejudices that
can overtake society
in the face of a national emergency
in short words matter indeed the wrong
words can be very harmful leaders who
promote stereotypes to use or he's
rhetoric aimed at a particular ethnic or
racial group can cause
increases in levels of discrimination or
violence directed against that group
when politicians use terms like china
virus
or kung flu or refer to covet 19
as the effect when they to refer to kova
19 is the effect intentional or not of
putting a target on the backs
of all asian americans use the right
way however words for our leaders can
help calm fears reassure
those feelings this feeling under threat
and remind everyone that we all share
the same basic negativity as human
beings
and that we should treat each other
accordingly thankfully we have two
panels of witnesses who can help
show us the way forward and legally
await their testimony
as best we can tell this the last time
there was a congressional hearing
specifically focused on
any asian hate was in 1987 before
this subcommittee that hearing took
place during another time when economic
and social problems were being blamed on
an asian country
and by unfair extension asian americans
you can't ever forget asian americans
not asians asian americans
clearly more work needs to be done let
us use this hearing as a chance to do
better
now like to recognize uh the ranking
member's not here
mr roy are you taking his place in lieu
of mr
johnson mr chip roy of texas will give
this statement for the
minority as the ranking member your
recognizement for five minutes mr roy
well thank you chairman cohen uh and i
appreciate uh
our gathering here today this is
obviously an important subject matter
um and to be clear all americans deserve
protection
and to live in a free and secure society
and we
the fundamental nature of what we expect
out of government
right secure the blessings of liberty as
we say in the constitution of the united
states
um the victims of race-based violence
uh and their families deserve justice
and as the case what we're talking about
here with the tragedy what we just saw
occur in
atlanta georgia i would also suggest
that the victims of
cartels moving illegal aliens deserve
justice the american citizens in south
texas that are getting
absolutely decimated by what's happening
our southern border deserve justice the
victims
of rioting and looting in the streets
last week businesses closed burn
i'm sorry last summer deserve justice um
we believe in justice right there's old
sayings in texas about you know find the
all the rope in texas and get a tall oak
tree uh
you know we take justice very seriously
and and
we ought to do that uh round up the bad
guys that's what we believe
um my concern about this hearing is that
it seems to want to venture into the
policing of rhetoric
in a free society free speech
and away from the rule of law
and taking out bad guys and as a former
federal prosecutor
i'm kind of predisposed and wired to
want to go take out bad guys
and that's bad guys of all colors that's
bad guys of all persuasions
that's bad guys targeting people uh for
all different reasons
and and i think we need to to be mindful
of that and so now we're talking about
whether talking about china
the chai comms the chinese communist
party whatever
phrasing we want to use and if some
people are saying hey we think those
guys are the bad guys
for whatever reason and let me just say
clearly i do
i think the chinese communist party
running
the country china i think they're the
bad guys and i think that they are
harming people
and i think they are engaging in modern
day slavery and i think that what
they're doing to the uyghurs and i think
that what they're doing targeting our
country and i think that what they're
doing to undermine our national security
and what they're doing to steal our
intellectual property and what they're
doing to build up their military and
rattle
uh throughout uh the pacific i think
it's
patently evil and deserving of
condemnation and i think that what they
did to hide
the reality of this virus is equally
deter
deserving of condemnation and there's
there's hardly any getting around that
that in fact happened
right we've got you know the world
health organization you know on twitter
saying preliminary investigation
conducted by the chinese authorities
found no clear evidence of human to
human transmission of the novel
coronavirus
who had to go back and redo all of that
we know full well i've got a bill that i
introduced to posthumously award a
congressional gold medal to dr
lee wen lang for coming out and exposing
what the chinese communist government
had done
to hide the virus dr wen lang was a 34
year old
ophthalmologist in wuhan china who died
from the 2019
coronavirus after he sought to draw
attention to the spread of the virus
research indicates the first patient
infected exhibited symptoms in early
december 2019
on january 3rd after raising concerns
about the spread dr wen lang and seven
other doctors were detained and
questioned by chinese officials
he was forced to sign a statement
retracting his warnings and confessing
he'd spread illegal rumors
uh that's the that's the reality and he
ended up dying but he was
beaten they were uh targeted for for
engaging in free speech
for trying to bring to light what was
happening and that's the reality
of what i tend to refer to as the chai
comms
and i i'm not going to be ashamed of
saying i oppose
the chai comms i oppose the chinese
communist party
and and when we say things like that and
we're talking about that
we shouldn't be worried about having a
committee of
members of congress policing our
rhetoric
because some evil doers go engaged in
some evil activity
as occurred in atlanta georgia
because when we start policing free
speech we're doing the very thing
that we're condemning when we condemn
what the chinese communist party
does to their country and that's exactly
where this wants to go this is the road
this wants to
head down and nothing could be more
dangerous
than going down that road because who
decides what is hate
who decides what is the kind of speech
that deserves
policing a panel
panel of this body a panel in the
executive branch a panel department of
justice
and then what does that mean who's
deciding
when we get into making crimes out of
thought
crimes out of speech as opposed to
crimes out of the actions
of evildoers find those who perpetrated
what happened in atlanta
find those who engage in hate
of all forms and punish the absolute
hell out of them
but don't go around policing thought and
i'd have one other thing i hope today's
hearings will examine this
discrimination against
asian americans in educational settings
a matter that the trump administration
prioritized took seriously enacted upon
in october for example the department of
justice sued yale
for raised in national origin
discrimination after determining that
yale is non-compliant with title vi of
the 64 civil rights act
which prohibits federal financial
assistance to any program engaged in
racially discriminatory practices
following a two-year investigation the
department of justice concluded that
asian-american white students
have only one-tenth to one-fourth of the
likelihood of admissions as
african-american applicants with
comparable academic credentials
the justice department alleged that yell
discriminated against asian americans by
favoring
certain applicants based upon their race
rather than looking
for race neutral alternatives to achieve
the university's goals
uh i and you know the then assistant
attorney general for the civil rights
division explained all persons who apply
for admission to colleges and
universities should expect to know that
they will be judged
by their character talents and
achievements and not the color of their
skin
to do otherwise to permit permit our
institutions to foster stereotypes
bitterness and division
i couldn't agree more however only two
weeks into president biden's term
the buy administration suddenly reverse
course and drop the lawsuit against yale
mr chairman i'll close but i'll just say
i hope this is the direction we'll go i
hope we'll look at this and we'll look
through the
lens of clarity and objective truth
trying to seek justice
and not trying to police speech and
trying to achieve the objectives we want
to achieve i thank the chairman
thank you mr roy and before i recognize
the chairman for his statement i'd just
like to
reiterate that while speech is important
and has meaning the incidents i
mentioned in my opening statement were
being spat at
slapped in the face lit on fire slashed
with a box cutter
and shoved violently to the ground as
the video showed that's not speech
mr chairman i didn't suggest it was
speech
that's not speech that's action um
i'd like to recognize the chairman for
his opening statement mr nadler
thank you mr chairman we're here today
to address the horrific rise
in violence harassment and
discrimination against asian americans
that are surging across the country
as we convene this hearing our thoughts
are with the victims
but especially the asian-american
victims in georgia who were brutally
murdered on tuesday night
although the motive is still to be
investigated the effect on the
asian-american community has been
profound
and it is certainly appropriate for us
to address the fear
gripping the asian-american community so
i want to thank the chairman for
convening this hearing
hate crimes and hate incidents against
asian americans have been on the rise
since 2017.
last year alone nearly 3 800 incidents
were reported
with about 68 of asian americans
reporting that they have experienced
racial slurs or verbal harassment
since the pandemic began distressingly
one of the largest increases in the
country of hatred and violence against
asian americans
has occurred in my own congressional
district in new york city
this short clip shows just some of the
verbal and physical abuse
many asian americans have faced in
recent years
a wave of violent unprovoked attacks
against asian americans
consuming the city of new york a 56 year
old man in manhattan this week
pummeled for no apparent reason a man
riding the subway
sliced across his face from cheek to
cheek a woman
viciously shoved in queens a 71 year old
woman
punched in her face in chinatown a 36
year old man stabbed in the back
now fighting to stay
last alive a woman was hit in the face
on the subway and called
diseased last march a chinese-american
dad from queens
and his ten-year-old son were harassed
and attacked by an assailant
who was screaming at him for appearing
to be chinese
last april an asian-american woman in
brooklyn suffered significant burns
after a chemical attack
last july an 89 year old grandmother in
bensonhurst
was attacked and set on fire by two men
just last month a new yorker was slashed
across the face with a box cutter
he needed more than a hundred stitches
also last month
in separate incidents on the same day
two elderly women were punched in the
face on the subway
a few weeks ago a man was stabbed
outside of the federal courthouse
and just this tuesday a woman in midtown
had an unknown liquid poured on her neck
as she was picking up packages
the common denominator all of the
victims were asian-american or evasion
descent
these are our neighbors our friends our
family members our constituents
and fellow americans and it is not only
severe violence that asian americans in
new york have had to fear
there's also been a barrage of verbal
attacks and discrimination against the
community
new yorkers have had racially derogatory
remarks written
on to the outside of their restaurants
and flyers posted around new york city
neighborhoods blaming asian americans
for the virus many of these attacks go
unreported
and official statistics represent only a
fraction of hate crimes or hate
incidents
these examples are certainly not
exhaustive and harassment abuse and
violence extend to communities across
the country
we have witnessed asian americans
bloodied and beaten in stores
learned that asian american parents fear
sending their children back to schools
because of
racial violence and observed harrowing
videos
of verbal attacks aimed at asian
americans in our public spaces
and perhaps even more heartbreaking we
have seen our asian-american front-line
workers battle not only the pandemic
but also racism and disproportionately
high death rates
it's important to recognize that this
surge did not spontaneously rise only
out of fears regarding the coronavirus
pandemic
some of this blame lies squarely on
political leaders who have demonized
china
both because of the virus and ongoing
geopolitical tensions
and in turn asian americans have fallen
in harm's way
words have power what we say
matters how we treat each other matters
the expectations of standards we set and
how we address
this pandemic matter
the conversation we're having today is
long overdue and it is vital that
congress shine a light on this issue
excuse me the last congressional hearing
held on violence against asian americans
was in 1987 in this subcommittee
34 years is too long for congress to
leave this issue untouched
our government must thoroughly
investigate and swiftly address
growing tensions and violence against
the asian-american community
especially in light of the pandemic
because lives and livelihoods are truly
at stake
last week we reached the one year
anniversary of the covet 19 pandemic in
this country
a solemn and difficult moment for our
nation as we reflected on all we have
suffered and lost
but such hardship cannot be used as an
excuse for dismissing the pain of our
fellow americans
enabling discrimination against them or
devaluing their sense of belonging and
citizenship
today we are privileged to have our
fellow members of congress from both
sides of the aisle
testifying about their personal
experiences
in addition we have an expert panel that
will walk us through the rise in
discrimination and violence
and its impact on the community as well
as historical perspectives and
challenges
to inform our legislative efforts moving
forward i look forward to hearing how we
can better ensure protection justice and
heat
healing for our asian american neighbors
in this time of crisis
and moving forward thank you and i yield
back
thank you mr nadler
we welcome our witnesses thank you for
participating today's hearing
i will now introduce each of the
witnesses and after each introduction
will recognize that witness for his or
her oral testimony
please note that each of your written
statements will be entered into the
record in its entirety
accordingly ask you to summarize your
testimony in five minutes
to help you stay within that five
minutes while you're testifying
there's a timing light on your table but
of course we don't
have a table um is there
is there a process okay yeah so on the
screen they can see
if it's green you're good if it's yellow
you're on the last minute and if it's
red
finish it uh it means your five minutes
are up
and that's on your webex view before
proceeding with the testimony i'd like
to remind all your wit all the witnesses
appearing on the panel that you have
legal obligation
provide truthful testimony and answers
any false statements you make today
could subject you to a prosecution under
section 101 of title 18 in the united
states code
today we have two witness panels our
first panel will be members
our first witness is representative
doris matsui congressman matsuy
represents the sixth congressional
district of california and is re
represented at area of sacramento and
environs
since 2005. congressman matsui you're
recognized for five minutes
apparently carson matsui you're
recognized for five minutes
apparently there's a technical problem
with webex and not with my
ipad
we're going to recess for as much time
as it's necessary to correct
this error technology is not
perfect
doris can you hear me
oh we're working on the communication
i'm i'm experiencing the same thing
okay my self goodness
uh we can hear you if you can hear us
wave your arms
they can't hear us
[Music]
wow
oh
wow
all right
oh
yes
all right
[Music]
is
they can't hurt
um
[Music]
good work team
oh
where's two
is
a group of people
[Music]
this is not
[Music]
[Music]
this is jeremy
[Music]
the hearing will now come back to order
now being in order i recognize the
distinguished lady from sacramento
california
the honorable doris matsui for five
minutes
thank you very much mr chairman ranking
member
and members of the committee for this
opportunity to testify
i'm very proud to join this
distinguished panel of our colleagues
and yet i wish it were not necessary
for us to be here under such troubling
circumstances
to address the disturbing spike in
discrimination and violence
against aapi communities across the
nation
just a couple of days ago eight people
six of whom were
women of asian descent were shot and
killed outside
of atlanta this latest attack stands as
a horrible reminder
of the fear and pain felt by the aapi
community across this country
i've lived an american story i grew up
on a farm in
california went to uc berkeley got a
great public education
i got married settled in sacramento with
my husband he raised our son
and i have the privilege to work on
public service in the white house and
here in congress
we work together on issues of health
care
and clean energy and all the issues that
really do
define us as a country but i have a
responsibility
and a moral obligation to speak out
about the normalizing
of attacks on the aapi community
since the beginning of the pandemic we
heard constant
hostile rhetoric directed at the api
committee including from leaders at the
highest levels
of our government there is a systemic
problem here
and we are duty bound to stop the spread
of xenophobic and racist ideas that have
escalated
to physical threats justice ruth bader
ginsburg
who fought against discrimination in a
remarkable life
used to talk about her mother and asked
questions what the difference was
between a bookkeeper in brooklyn's
garment district and a supreme court
justice
her answer one generation
this kind of family history is essential
to understanding
american history we all share the charge
to ensure that our country not only
learns from but does not
forget his past because of my history
and background i know i have a duty to
speak up
future generations are listening
especially my grandchildren
in 1942 president franklin d roosevelt
signed
executive order 9066 approving the
removal of american citizens of japanese
descent to remote camps
my parents and grandparents were among
120 000 forced to leave
their homes and businesses they were
sent by their own government
our government to a camp and post in
arizona
they lived in appalling conditions
surrounded by
a barbed wire fence armed guards on
towers
incarcerated solely the removal of
american citizens of japanese descent to
remote camps
my parents and grandparents were among
120 000 forced to leave
their homes and businesses they were
sent by their own government
our government to a camp in poston
arizona
they lived in appalling conditions
surrounded by a barbed wire fence
armed guards on towers incarcerated
solely because of their ancestry
despite the good fortune in my life i am
not even
one generation removed from that
experience
i was born in the a post-internment camp
but because i was
a baby i have no personal memories
and my parents rarely talked to me about
their time there
i had an ordinary childhood i think my
parents didn't want
to burden me with that experience they
just wanted me to move forward and reach
for the stars
i would hear conversations from time to
time about life in the camp
i sort of knew what happened but i did
not realize at that time
how much your lives have been turned
upside down
it's when i went to college that i met
students whose parents were very
affected by the internment
and we started talking the vast majority
of the people who were sent to him
were american citizens and you wonder
how did this happen
it was then that we all realized that
we had to learn more about it it is part
of our family history
it is part of american history during
world war
ii many were blinded by prejudice our
government and many of us leaders
advanced the myth
that the japanese american community was
inherently the enemy
americans across the country believed it
exceeded to institutionalize racism and
acted on it
it was not uncommon to accuse an
innocent person of violating our
country's trust
with no evidence this societal trust
shift
shift to accept and normalize wrongdoing
was exactly what kept japanese americans
in prison
for over three years these were
americans who previously lived normal
lives they owned homes
shops farmers doctors lawyers teachers
just regular folks who betrayed by their
country because of a dangerous
spiral of injustice last year
when i heard the highest levels of
government
those people use racist lures like china
virus
to spread xenophobia and cast blame on
innocent communities
it was all too familiar commas like
these
only build upon the legacy of racism
anti-aging sentiment and insensitivity
that seeks to divide
our nation so yes i was deeply shaken by
the end recurrence in our nation
the heated discourse at the highest
levels
of our government cannot be viewed in
isolation from the ensuing
ensuing violence in our communities the
fear of the
other whether racial religious or tribal
that works to suppress
the better angels of our nature we've
seen the consequences when we go down
this path
my family has lived through these
consequences this is what we are working
to
root out from the deepest place in our
social conscience
after the incarceration of the japanese
american community
our country moved on for decades without
coming to terms with what our government
did
and what many americans turned a blind
eye to
it took decades for testimonies to be
heard in congress
it took decades for lawmakers to hear
our pain
my late husband bob matsui was first
elected to congress in 1978
and served on the ways and means
committee he loved that work
but because of his parents experience
the experience of the japanese-american
community
he passionately believed that justice
could not be
denied and therefore devoted a more
enormous amount of time and dedication
to the passage of the civil liberties
act of 1988
by which the united states government
apologized a token compensation
to the japanese americans who had been
incarcerated
bob said on the floor debate on that
legislation
that he believed it was possible because
this is a great
and wonderful country today's hearing is
another reminder that our country is
capable of growth
that this legislative body will no
longer sit
in silence while our communities suffer
racism and hatred
now is the time to commit recommit to
moving forward with a shared vision for
our future
based upon basic human dignity again i
thank the chairman and ranking member
and i yield back thank you thank you
congressman matt sewie for that
history and that uh testimony our next
witness is representative judy chu
congressman two represents the 27th
congressional district of california
which includes
pasadena polytechnic school and the san
gabriel valley in that order
she's been a member of congress since
2009 among other things
she's chair of the congressional asian
pacific american caucus
congressman chu you're recognized for
five minutes
uh congressman if you need to unmute
unmute
uh thank you
um so much
we hear you thank you ranking member
jordan subcommittee chairman
cohen ranking member johnson and other
distinguished members
of the committee for the opportunity to
testify
before you today it is with a heavy
heart that we are here today
still shocked and heartbroken about the
murder
of eight in georgia including six asian
american women
by a gunman who targeted three asian
businesses
the first one being young's asian
massage then
driving 27 miles to two other asian spas
his targets were no accident
and what we know is that this day
was coming and because of crimes like
this
i as chair of the congressional asian
pacific american
caucus or capex urged the committee to
undertake
this hearing because the asian american
community
has reached a crisis form that cannot be
ignored since the beginning of the covet
19 pandemic
asian americans have been terrified by
the alarming surge in anti-asian bigotry
and violence we have witnessed across
our nation
in fact it was over one year ago that
kpac first began to sound the alarm
bells about the anti-asian
discrimination
we were beginning to see due to
misinformation
and stigma that wrongly associated asian
americans
with the coronavirus but what started
out last january's
dirty looks and verbal assaults has
escalated to physical attacks and
violence
against innocent asian americans and
these attacks have
increasingly become more deadly just as
many
asian americans were preparing for the
lunar new year last month
we saw a surge in anti-asian violence
many of the victims have been older and
vulnerable
like fisher ratanapakti an 84 year old
thai man in san francisco
who was killed in an unprovoked assault
while on this morning walk in new york
61 year old noel quintana's face
was slashed from ear to ear with a box
cutter in the subway
requiring 100 stitches in oakland's
chinatown account captured a 91 year old
man being thrown to the ground
by an assailant in my own congressional
district a chinese-american man was
attacked
at a bus stop in rosemary with his own
cane causing him to lose
part of his finger this has become
almost a daily tragedy
and has a chilling effect on our
community
today we find that there have been
nearly 3 800
anti-asian hate crimes and incidents in
just the year alone
they were stoked by the words of former
president donald trump
who sought to shift blame and anger away
from his
own flawed response to the corona he
used
racial slurs like lujan virus china
plague
and kun flu despite the fact that the
cdc
and the world health organization warned
not to associate
the virus with a specific ethnicity
country or geographic region
due to the stigma it causes immediately
we in kpac took donald trump on about
this racist terminology
we issued statements held press
conferences and sent letters
but our pleas and the guidance from
experts were ignored
instead he doubled down on using these
slurs directing more hate and blame
at the asian american community over the
past
year hostile anti-aging covert comments
on twitter
increased by 900 and we saw a nearly 150
surge in anti-asian hate crimes in major
u.s cities
and even though donald trump is no
longer president i believe the most
recent
round of anti-asian attacks are the
aftermath of one year
of hateful attacks and four years of
ugly comments
about immigrants and people of color
that's why i'm so grateful that we have
a new president joe biden
who's working to stop these attacks not
incite them
within his first week in president
president biden
issued a presidential memorandum to
combat and condemn xenophobia
against aapis and ensure that the
department of justice works with our
community
to address these surging hate crimes
but congress must do its part as well
that's why k-pac pushed for legislation
such as congresswoman grace maine's
resolution
to condemn anti-asian sentiment related
to covet 19
which passed the house last fall and
that's why it's important to pass
critical legislation
like congress member buyer's no hate act
and congresswoman men's covet 19 hate
crimes act
that will help us to better track
and respond to hate crimes and incidents
against asian americans we're calling
for a national day
to speak out against asian hate
on march 26 it
is time that we continue
to push back against xenophobia every
time
it reares its ugly head asian americans
must
not be used as scapegoats in times of
crisis
lives are at stake and it's critical
that congress takes bold action
to address this pandemic of
discrimination
and hate
thank you congressman i remember the
smog in the san gabriel valley
our next witness is senator tammy
duckworth and after her we'll hear from
representative young kim senator
duckworth represents the state of
illinois in the united states senate
first elected in 2016. she previously
served in the united states house of
representatives
and she represented the eighth
congressional district of illinois for
two terms
she has an outstanding communications
team and
outstanding record in congress senator
duckworth you're recognized for five
minutes
thank you mr chairman and it was a
pleasure to serve alongside you
previously in the house it's good to see
you up on the dyess today
thank you for this hearing in new york
as we've heard an 89 year old was
slapped
and in california a 91 year old was
pushed to the ground
in the middle of a park a little girl
was shoved off her bike and in the
middle of a city sidewalk
a little boy watched and his father was
beaten up
families have had rocks thrown at them
nurses have been spit on
heroes front line workers hospital staff
have been blamed
for covet 19 and they've been denied
service treated as other than
as less than simply because they are
members of the aapi community
and now less than 48 hours ago six
members of the asian american community
were murdered in atlanta georgia
another unspeakable tragedy after a year
of
unfathomable cruelty there's nothing
nothing we can say today that will piece
back together the shattered lives of the
victims
loved ones there's nothing we can do
that will give them the solace they
deserve
nothing we can provide that will even
begin to make sense of this senseless
tragedy
but what we can say and should say
clearly
unambiguously is that blaming the aapi
community
for a public health crisis is racist and
wrong
and continuing to treat our fellow
americans as others
only further divides our country at a
time when we should be pushing
pooling tugging at our nation with all
our might
until it lives up to its founding ideals
of equality
and justice for all unfortunately
this type of prejudice is far from new
it's a similar brand of discrimination
to the one that marred some of our
country's darkest days
and toughest fights from segregation to
immigration
as congressman she has mentioned it's in
a similar vein to what was witness in
world war
ii as our nation incarcerated japanese
americans because of their heritage
and trapped thousands of families like
congresswoman matsui's
even as their loved ones sacrificed
everything
on the warfront to defend our nation
overseas
fortunately the united states government
recognized that this type of bigotry was
unamerican yet the risk of repeating
past grave errors is real
and chilling that's why i introduced the
korimatsu takai civil liberties
protection act
which would be a first step towards
safeguarding freedom and establishing a
clear statutory prohibition against
un-american policies
that seek to imprison or otherwise
detain american citizens
on the basis of who they are rather than
what they have done
and as the daughter of an american
vietnam veteran and an immigrant with
chinese thai heritage
i am deeply committed to supporting our
community's fight against discrimination
i applaud the efforts of this
subcommittee to raise awareness of this
crisis
and to discuss a plan to advance civil
rights for asian americans and protect
the well-being of
all of our families you know the
american story as we know it would not
exist without the strength of the aapi
community
quite literally asian americans helped
build this country
with their bare hands and bent backs
they laid the railroad tracks that
connected us from coast to coast
they tilled the fields and started the
businesses that picked
and also picked up the rifles necessary
to develop and defend
this nation that we all love and today
even as we face so much bigotry and
violence
our community is helping to keep the
country running
so i just want to take a minute to thank
all the incredible
heroic frontline workers who are getting
our nation through this crisis
from the doctors and the nurses risking
their own lives to try to save the lives
of strangers
to the cashier the market who's helping
our families stay fed
from janitors sweeping up hospital rooms
at night to the teachers patiently
helping our kids learn their abcs of
resume
i hope you know that we see you and we
see your sacrifices and that we are
forever in your debt
we'll never be able to fully express our
gratitude for all of the apis on the
front lines
but every hour of every day i'm going to
keep trying because that's the least
that these folks deserve
so i want to say thank you one more time
for everything that they do
and going forward i hope that all
americans will speak up against such
hatred towards their neighbors and i
look forward to continuing
to work with presidents biden's
executive order that assist states and
community organizations
make this kind of discrimination a thing
of the past
please know that we have so much work
ahead of us and i thank this committee
for holding his hearing to shed a light
on this very very serious issue
that will divide our nation and make us
weaker
not stronger with that i yield back mr
chairman thank you
thank you senator it's nice to see you
and have you back in the house again
now we'd like to recognize a new member
of the house representative young
kim uh representative kim
uh represents the ninth 39th
congressional district of california
which includes the northern parts of
orange county
not sure if she's got the big a in
anaheim the ballpark or the
disney world or the knightsbury farm or
those places but they're all out there
first selected in 2020 you're recognized
for five minutes please
thank you chairman and ranking member
and the members of the committee for
holding this hearing today
on a very important topic that has been
prevalent in our national conversation
but one that is very very personal to me
as an asian american i represent
california's 39th congressional district
this is one of the most diverse
districts in the country
and it's also a home to a vibrant asian
american community
my district is truly a representation of
america
and what makes our country great asian
americans
have and continue to make countless
contributions to communities across the
country
and right here in the halls of congress
since the beginning of kobe 19 we have
increasingly seen asian americans
becoming targets of hate across the
nation
with more than 3 000 hate crimes against
the asian american and pacific islander
community
those crimes have been reported
nationwide with an
increased number of attacks against
seniors
this week we saw senseless violence in
atlanta that took the lives of six
asian american women where the
investigation is ongoing and we wait for
more information
this comes during a time when violence
and attacks against asian americans are
on the rise
the hate the bias and the attacks that
we've seen against the asian american
community
are unacceptable and they must be
stopped
this is wrong and it has no place in our
political discourse
and it's contrary to the values that
america stands for
this should not have to be said but i
want to be very clear
no american of any race or ethnic group
is responsible for the kobe 19 pandemic
the virus does not discriminate it
affects everyone
we must come together as americans not
just to fight coven 19
but also to stand against the rise of
hate and discrimination against the aapi
community
and any other group of americans we also
cannot forget that discrimination we've
seen against the aapi community
is not limited to the violence and
attacks
i hope we can look at the nation's elite
universities
and other institutions of learning we
have seen institutions discriminating
against asian americans in their
admissions process
in order to deny them the entry
discrimination is
wrong and goes against our fundamental
american values that we hold dear
in america we value the individual
and we believe that people deserve to be
judged on their merits
and not penalized because of their
heritage race or background
these are the values that my family and
countless of immigrants came here for
when our country seems more divided than
ever
we should work together to unify our
country
and ensure future generations of
americans
regardless of their background have the
same opportunity to access the promise
of america
no matter our race or background we are
all americans asian americans are
americans
as an asian american and a member of
congress
i feel a duty to speak out so i stand
with the aapi community
today and always so i want to thank you
for allowing me to speak on this very
very important issue
and i impact the balance of my time
thank you
thank you congressman kim our next
witness is representative michelle park
steele
congressman steele represents the 48th
congressional district in california
which includes
other portions of orange county she was
first selected in 2020 congressman
steele you're recognized for five
minutes
chairman steve cohen and ranking member
chief roy
thank you for holding this important
conversation today
it has been heartbreaking to see the
rise in
anti-asian american hate and harassment
over the last year as we will hear
today from our witnesses and we've been
hearing from our witnesses
hate against the asian american
community is not
new according to sean ooh a former
federal
prosecutor violence against asian
americans
have been under scrutinized
underprosecuted and often condoned
this is a long sad history of
intolerance
and hate directed at our community
and in the last year almost 4 000
instances
of verbal harassment physical assault
and discrimination have been reported
california is at the top of the list
with 44
of all incidents reported happening in
my home state new york is second on the
list
making up 13 of all the incidents
reported
68 of these incidents and crimes
were targeted towards asian american
women
this has to stop when i was chair
of the orange county board of
supervisors i
introduced a resolution that called for
tolerance
and contention towards all residents and
condemned discrimination against the
aapi
community i was proud this year to
introduce a similar resolution in
congress
with other orange county congresswoman
katie porter that's because combating
hate is not a partisan issue
we can all agree that violence against
any community
should never be tolerated as a
first-generation korean-american
who is now serving her community in the
halls of congress
this is my american dream i want future
generations of americans to know
they can achieve anything in this great
country
that's why i also like to use some of my
time today to talk about the
discrimination
that the aapi community is experiencing
in our nation's education system it is
one of the reasons
why my colleagues represented kim
and i joined ranking member jordan and
subcommittee
ranking member johnson to request the
president of yale university to testify
at the today's hearing last year
the department of justice filed a case
alleging that yale university was
discriminating against
asian-american and white africans
but the biden administration dropped the
suit last month
this is totally wrong and sets a
dangerous precedent
in 1996 i supported and campaigned for
california's proposition 209
which banned racial preferences
in public hiring education and
contracting
it was modeled after the civil rights
act
before prop 209 was cast the four-year
graduation rate for underrepresented
racial minorities in the university of
california system was 31.3
by 2014 that has increased
to 51.1 percent
the six-year graduation rate is even
better increasing from 66.5
in 1998 to 75.1 percent in 2013.
last year in california democrats
introduced proposition 16
to bring back racial preferences in
hiring contracting and our education
system
californians overwhelmingly rejected it
as a new member of congress and
immigrant to this country
we should be encouraging all students
and young people to succeed
especially in our education system
discrimination is against the
fundamental value of american culture
and that includes discrimination against
d aapi
community in the halls of our schools
and universities
this is wrong this type of behavior is
only hurting
future generations we should be working
together to stop this discrimination
and hate in its tracks and to encourage
the next generation to achieve
their own american dream i thank you the
committee
for the opportunity to testify and share
this with you today
i yield back
thank you congressman steele congressman
woman steele thank you very much
final witness on this first panel is the
honorable representative grace ming
congressman ming represents the 6th
congressional district of the empire
state new york
includes flushing bayside fresh meadows
and other portions of northeastern
queens
she's been in congress since 2013.
congressman ming you're now recognized
for five minutes
you chairman adler chairman cohen
ranking member thompson
and distinguished members of this
committee for organizing today's hearing
the topic is discrimination and violence
against asian americans
some of us seem to be going a little off
topic i'm not sure why
for over a year asian americans have
been fighting
an additional virus of hate and bigotry
anti-asian rhetoric like china virus
kung flu
misinformation racism have left asian
americans
traumatized and fearful for their lives
mr roy mentioned the who and it's the
same world health organization
that actually said not to use countries
of origin
when we're referring to diseases since
last year there have been over 3 800
reported incidents
of anti-aging hate but we know that the
majority of incidents
go reported and in fact nearly 70
percent
of reported anti-asian hate incidents
have happened to asian american women
in fact just this week we saw the
terrible news about the six
asian women who were shot and killed in
the atlanta area
our community is bleeding we are in pain
and for the last year we've been
screaming
out for help asian-american
discrimination however
is not new in this country from the 1882
chinese exclusion act to the world war
ii incarceration of japanese americans
and from the 1975 police brutality
in manhattan's chinatown to the 1982
murder of vincent chen
discrimination against asian americans
is a shameful part of our history
unfortunately so much of this history is
not taught in our schools
excluding asian americans from our
history books renders us invisible
and deems us the perpetual foreigner in
fact history has excluded the history
of asian americans black americans
latino and native americans
and that has led to the systemic
inequities at many institutions
including our academic institutions
in the 116th congress i introduced my
resolution
to condemn anti-asian sentiment related
to covet and i was grateful my
resolution
passed the house with bipartisan support
except for 164 of our republican
colleagues
who voted against it even though some
had the audacity to tweet condolences
after atlanta's tragedy
i'm glad to hear about my colleague
representative steele's resolution
and i hope that she has better luck
getting her party to support
the resolution during this last year it
became painfully apparent that we need a
comprehensive effort
from our local communities to the
federal level that's why i support bills
like the no hate act and that's why
senator hirono and i introduced the kobe
19 hate crimes act
which would assign a point person to the
department of justice
to quickly review hate crimes and to
make it easier
for people to report these incidents my
bill also
builds on president biden's presidential
memorandum by directing relevant federal
agencies to work with community-based
organizations
to find ways to talk about the virus in
a way that is not racist
i urge my colleagues on this committee
for swift consideration
of these bills we cannot turn a blind
eye to
people living in fear i want to go back
to something that mr roy said earlier
your president and your party and your
colleagues
can talk about issues with any other
country that you want
but you don't have to do it by putting a
bullseye
on the back of asian americans across
this country
on our grandparents on our kids this
hearing
was to address the hurt and pain of our
community
and to find solutions and we will not
let you take our voice away from us
thank you i yield back
congressman thank you very much
you're correct about the genesis of this
hearing
now we will go to our second panel
the second number of panels should turn
their cameras on
there we go i think we're coming along
there
first member panel can turn their
cameras off
great light show
i guess we're ready we're going to be
ready we're now on our second panel on
our first witness is mr john yang mr
yang is president and executive director
of asian americans advancing justice
the aajc which seeks to advance the
civil
and human rights of asian americans and
to build and promote a fair and
equitable society for all
through policy advocacy education and
litigation
he received a jd from george washington
university school of law and his ba from
washington university in st
louis mr yang you were recognized for
five minutes
thank you very much and thank you very
much chair chairman
cohen thank you to the ranking member
ranking member johnson
and the other members of the committee
really appreciate the opportunity to
testify before all of you today
and i really appreciate the powerful
words from representative ming and the
other tpec members
as to why we are here today when i
agreed to testify at this hearing
no one could have imagined that this
would come two days after the horrific
shooting in atlanta georgia
and so i also want to take a moment to
recognize and honor the victims and
their families
and the suffering that they are going
through at this moment and to remember
that we must center ourselves
in in the atlanta community and all the
local communities
that have been affected during this past
year with respect to the anti-asian
violence
look for a year now asian americans have
been fighting two viruses
the covet-19 pandemic affecting all of
us as well as this virus of racism
asian americans like all americans have
suffered economic and health
consequences
of cobit 19 but at the same time asian
americans have been at the front lines
as essential workers in grocery stores
in delivery trucks
in custodial services as well as in
health professions
unfortunately asian americans have also
been fighting the second virus this
virus of racism
we have long struggled for visibility
and equity and now our communities are
faced with this additional
physical and mental harm that is arising
out of the cloven 19 pandemic
as ms call carney will testify web-based
self-reporting tools have reported a
tremendous increase
in the number of anti-aging heat that we
have seen this past year
a pew report from last year confirmed
what that data shows
that a majority of asian americans say
it is more common
for people to blame asians for cloven 19
and have expressed insensitive and
completely inappropriate views about
asian americans
than before kova 19. an ipso survey
shows the same thing
where over 30 percent of the american
population
say that they have witnessed harassment
or blame of the asian community
for covet 19 and 60 of the the asian
american population
showed that this was similar behavior
that they were seeing so these fears are
real
you know and the other thing is the
impact on the asian american communities
is clear with respect to their
businesses
as noted in a report by mckenzie and
company misguided fears of their virus
effectively shuttered businesses
in many asian american cultural
districts a full month before lockdowns
began nationwide
our organization and others started
talking about this issue in late january
when we saw this happening
and i
both districts during that time when
when
we saw this happening and to say that it
was still safe to go there before the
lockdowns
in new york as demonstrated by a study
by our community partner asian american
federation
there has been record job losses for the
asian american community in new york
there was a 6
000 increase in unemployment benefit
applications
from february through june of 2020 and
asian america suffered the largest
increase in unemployment
going from three percent in february of
2020 to over 25 percent
now look asian-american racism is rooted
in two very dangerous stereotypes
that of the perpetual foreigner and that
of the model minority
the perpetual foreign suggests that we
can be here and we could be born here
and we can live here as long as
we want but we are still seen as
foreigners we are still seen as the
other
not not to be trusted and to be feared
on the flip side of that stereotype is
the so-called model minority
to suggest that asian americans are held
up as a good people of color
when it is convenient to plant seeds of
division within allied communities of
color
and here i will call out people that try
to use affirmative action as a wedge
to drive between asian americans and
other communities of color
that model minority myth hides the
complexities of our community
and the economic disparities that exist
among asian americans
even as the cult 19 epidemic recedes
we must remember that all anti-asian
racism is likely to continue
we do have legitimate concerns and
geopolitical differences
with the chinese government and the
chinese communist party but that is
likely to remain for the
foreseeable future but if we are not
careful
those differences will have consequences
on our asian american community
and we can expect a backlash against our
community we've seen that happen with
the japanese american community in world
war
ii we've seen that happen with the arab
middle eastern most of the south asian
american community
after 9 11 and we saw that happen with
the murder of vincent chin
in 1982 we have to do better than that
we have to have the proper nuance to
call out xenophobia
racism whenever it occurs against our
community
and we must call out this out to stop
this cycle of
violence it is only then that we will
stop seeing asian americans
as this professional foreigner to be
feared and come
up to a better place in addressing this
racism thank you very much
i look forward to your questions
thank you mr yang our next witness is
manju shah cool carney
she's executive director of the asian
pacific policy and planning council
a coalition of over 40 community-based
organizations that serve and represent
the 1.5 million asian american and
pacific islanders in los angeles county
she's also a co-founder of stop aapi
hate
an online self-reporting and tracking
tool launched on march 19
2020 in response to a sharp rise in
anti-asian
xenophobia and bigotry resulting from
the references to the coveted 19
pandemics providence
she received her jd from boston
university school of law
and her ba from duke university
miss cool carney you are now recognized
for five minutes
is did you hear me you're recognized for
five minutes
you may need to unmute
did we lose sound again can anybody hear
me
amy this isn't my fault
we will have a five-minute recess and
we'll be back
thanks for waiting we've let the host
know that you're here
testing testing
this is john yang i can hear you great
we're back we're back recess is over
no more milk and cookies miss cool
carney you're recognized for five
minutes
unbeaten
unmute thank you chairman
ranking member and distinguished members
of the subcommittee for the opportunity
to testify
before you today go back to wuhan and
take the virus with you
you are the reason for the coronavirus
damn another asian riding with me hope
you don't have covid
these are but a few examples of what
asian americans have experienced over
the course of the last year
alongside with refusal of service
workplace discrimination and sadly now
homicide for that reason on march 19
2020 my organization asian pacific
policy and planning council in
conjunction with chinese for affirmative
action and san francisco state
university's asian american studies
department launched stop aapi
hate in the past 11 months we have
received almost
3 800 self-reported incidents of bias
and discrimination
from all 50 states and the district of
columbia making stop at api hate the
nation's leading aggregator
of asian american hate from our analysis
the following trends have emerged
68 of incidents involve verbal
harassment
20 involve avoidance or shunning
11 percent physical assault and 9
civil rights violations including
refusal of service
vandalism workplace discrimination and
discrimination
in housing the vast majority do not
involve
a hate crime businesses including
grocery stores pharmacies and big
box retail are the primary side of
discrimination
this is followed by public streets and
public parks
the fact that so many incidents take
place at businesses is
especially concerning given that retail
venues sell goods necessary for daily
living
essential during a pandemic given that
30
35 percent of incidents occur in public
spaces is also
worrisome these figures give credence
to the anxiety felt by apis that
purchasing food
refilling prescriptions or simply going
on a walk
might leave them vulnerable to being
attacked
our data indicates that especially
vulnerable populations including
women youth and seniors have reported
experiencing anti-aging hate incidents
at significant rates
as has been noted 68 percent of incident
reports
come from women this is perhaps to be
expected given the lessons learned from
the metoo movement
and a survey of stop street harassment
which found that 81 percent of women
experience straight harassment
in their daily lives while chinese
americans have often been the explicit
target of perpetrators they make up only
42 percent
of individuals who reported to our site
fifteen percent identify as korean
americans
nine percent is vietnamese and eight
percent is filipino-american
we have also received reports from south
asian americans as well as pacific
islanders and others
evidencing the fact that asian americans
across ethnic
ethnicities are experiencing hate and
racism today
with our pacific islanders sisters and
brothers
sadly the 3 800 reported to stop
aapi hate represent only a fraction
of what has happened in this country the
widespread nature
of anti-asian hate is confirmed by a
study by the
pew research center released last july
that found that three in 10
asian americans experienced racist jokes
and slurs
similarly a poll by the center for
public integrity found that
60 percent of asian americans have
witnessed someone blaming our community
for coven 19.
before i close i want to acknowledge the
tremendous mobilization done by asian
american groups in georgia
in response to the violence there and
read a portion of their statement
during this time of broader crisis and
trauma in our asian american communities
we must be guided by a compass of
community care
that prioritizes assessing and
addressing our communities
immediate needs including in language
support for mental health
legal employment and immigration
services
we must stand firm in decrying misogyny
systemic violence and white supremacy
in addition to sharing our data and the
statement from
georgia advocates i want to share the
fact that we have been developing
resources for community members
who experience incidents of hate and
providing direct assistance through
local networks
we are also closely working with local
state and federal policy
makers to address the hate incidents
that have occurred and seek to prevent
additional incidents
from taking place in the future thank
you for the opportunity to testify and i
look forward to taking any questions
thank you very much and you were perfect
on the five minutes
our next witness is erica lee she's a
regents professor of history in asian
american studies and the director of the
immigration history research center at
the university of minnesota
she's the author of four award-winning
books including america for americans a
history of xenophobia in the united
states
which won the 2020 american book award
in the 2020 asian pacific american award
for literature professor lee received
her m.a and phd in history
from the university of california
berkeley and our ba from tufts
university
professor lee you're now recognized for
five minutes
thank you so much chairman cohen and
members of the committee i'm
so honored to join you i also want to
thank all
of the congressional staffers who have
helped to make this hearing possible
as we've just heard from my fellow
witnesses anti-asian racism and violence
has risen
alarmingly as shocking as these
incidents are it is so vital to
understand
that they are not random acts
perpetrated by deranged individuals
they are an expression of our country's
long history of systemic racism
targeting asian americans and pacific
islanders
we've heard in the past 24 hours many
describe anti-asian discrimination and
racial violence
as un-american unfortunately
it is very american this history
this american history is over 150 years
old
let me share just a few examples in 1871
17 chinese were lynched by a mob of 500
in los angeles this was the largest mass
lynching in u.s history
in 1886 a mob of 1500
forced out all of seattle's chinese
residents
in the early 20th century south asians
were expelled from cities
and filipino-americans and
japanese-americans were attacked
most recently in 1982 vincent chin a
chinese-american was beaten to death in
detroit
because his attackers thought he was
japanese and blamed him
for the economic decline in the auto
industry
throughout the 1980s attacks on korean
shopkeepers and southeast
asian refugees were widespread after 9
11
hate crimes targeting muslim middle
eastern and south asian americans
increased by
1600 percent as these incidents reveal
asian americans have been terrorized
we've been treated as enemies
we've been discriminated against today
we
are still viewed as foreigners rather
than u.s citizens
the government of this country has not
just
ignored this problem it has been part
of the problem throughout much of our
history congress and other elected
officials have promoted
and legalized anti-asian racism through
its laws
and its actions in 1875
congress passed the so-called page act
which effectively barred the entry of
chinese women
because lawmakers believed that all
chinese women were prostitutes
in 1882 congress passed the chinese
exclusion act
the first federal law singling out an
entire group
for immigration exclusion based on race
by the 1930s
all other asian groups japanese korean
south asians
filipinos were also barred from the us
and prevented from becoming naturalized
citizens
asian immigration did not fully open up
again until
1965. in 1942 president roosevelt signed
an executive order that allowed for the
incarceration
of 120 000 japanese americans as
prisoners without trial
and i want to thank representative matt
stewie so much for sharing
her own family's history so that we
never forget the real consequences of
racism
for many years after 9 11 not just
right after the terrorist attacks but
for many years after south asian
americans face systemic racism
in the form of profiling by government
agencies
during this past year some of our
highest elected officials deliberately
and consistently used racist language
tying covenanting to asians
this included the phrases that we've
been talking about
this morning chinese virus wuhan virus
and also telling americans to quote
unquote
blame china for the pandemic these
words matter especially when they
repeatedly came from the white house
during the previous administration
researchers have found that the
anti-asian rhetoric promoted by leaders
directly correlated
with a rise in racist incidents against
asian americans
this history of racism is not taught in
our schools
instead many americans believe the
deceptive
model minority stereotype portraying
asian americans only
as success stories proving that aapi's
do indeed
experience structural racism and
institutionalized discrimination
remains a persistent challenge the last
time and seemingly the only
other time in our country's history that
congress has held hearings on anti-asian
racism
was 34 years ago before this committee
over 20 million in number asian
americans are now the fastest growing
racial group
in the united states we are your
constituents
but we are in crisis from the multiple
and disproportionate
effects of the pandemic on our diverse
aapi communities
u.s citizens are being told to go back
to their own countries
nurses and doctors on the front lines
are subjected to racist tirades
as we've seen in atlanta asian-owned
businesses and workers are being
attacked
and all of this violence especially
targets women
like all americans aapis are struggling
with the public health crisis and the
shuttered economy
that we also have to worry about being
attacked
or harassed in our own neighborhoods
makes our pandemic experience
even more difficult congress needs to
act definitively
and immediately to address the enduring
problem of anti-asian racism
in the u.s the acts facing aapis today
are a systemic national
tragedy they will not simply go away
after the pandemic
we call upon our leaders to condemn
racism in all of its forms
invest in aapi communities and support
individuals who have experienced
race-based violence we cannot afford to
wait
another 34 years for congress to act
thank you very much
thank you professor lee our next witness
is charles layman
mr layman is a fellow with the manhattan
institute working primarily on the
policing and public safety initiative
he is also contributing editor of city
journal mr layman receives his ba from
yale university
mr lehmann you're recognized for five
minutes
uh thank you to the committee for the
invitation to speak today
about the important issue of rising
crime against asian americans
many of our fellow citizens now fear for
their safety in their own neighborhoods
i am glad this matter has not escaped
congress's attention particularly in
light of tuesday's awful shooting
outside of atlanta
i am speaking today as a researcher
focused on crime
and it is in that capacity that i want
to offer two points
the first is that while some of these
offenses were doubtless motivated by
bias
you should be cautious when interpreting
the broader trend
solely as a spike in hate crimes the
second relatedly
is that these crimes should be
understood as part of a larger surge in
violence
as you're aware crime is rising in
several asian american communities
particularly in the greater bay area in
new york city there have been reports of
assaults
daylight robberies and general mayhem
targeting asian citizens
especially the elderly many have
identified these offenses as hate crimes
linking them to bigoted sentiments
inspired by the coronavirus pandemic
the fbi which tracks such offenses
defines a hate crime as one motivated
by an offender's quote bias against a
race religion disability
sexual orientation ethnicity gender or
gender identity
last spring saw a spike in hate crimes
against asian americans
as major cities experienced the 150
increase over 2019
this was doubtless driven by rhetoric
blaming asians for the coronavirus
crisis
in the latest wave some offenses are
plainly biased motivated
like the attack in seattle which
assailant samuel greene told catherine
yeager
asians need to be put in your place as
she shoved her to the ground
but not all of the recent cases are so
clear-cut the reason for tuesday's
terrific shootings in atlanta remains
unclear
but police suspect it was not racially
motivated
law enforcement in both new york and
northern california are reportedly not
investigating many of the high-profile
offenses
as hate crimes other factors are likely
at play
consider yaya muslim arrested for
shoving three asian adults including a
91 year old
in oakland's chinatown muslim who's
homeless has a history of mental illness
which his defense counsel blames for the
attack
council for antoine watson who allegedly
shoved and killed 84 year old witcher
right on a party in san francisco
has also appealed to the teenager's
mental health rejecting charges of bias
other cases start to look different
given context filipino new yorker noel
quintana was a victim of a
subway knife attack that somehow called
racially motivated
but several other non-asian victims have
also recently been slashed on the mta
part of rising transit crime which swept
up qantana
my purpose in making these points is not
to deny the role biases played in some
offenses
or to downplay the seriousness of
anti-asian bigotry
i want to condemn in no uncertain terms
hate crimes of all sorts
they are particularly vicious species of
offense motivated by special animus and
deserving of special denunciation
no american should have to face
discrimination of any kind
rather i wish to emphasize to the
committee that if they analyze these
offenses solely as hate crimes
they will miss critical context and
thereby risk making under-informed
decisions
in particular we cannot discuss these
offenses without highlighting the past
year's violent crime wave
criminologist jeff asher has estimated
that 2020 saw the largest one-year spike
in homicides on record
as murder increased by more than 30
percent in nearly 40 major cities
new data indicate the trend has
persisted into early 2021.
that pattern appears in cities where
asian residents are being attacked
in san francisco homicide was up 17
in new york homicides risked 40 while
shootings nearly doubled
in oakland 2020 saw the highest homicide
rate in eight years
and the city's on track for worst 2021
with 157 dead
the atlanta journal constitution called
2020 the city's deadliest year in
decades
that violence is a product of three
roman criminals
pearl chan head of oakland's chinatown
chamber of commerce
describes how quote businesses are so
fearful they prefer to close early
we also have many juveniles driving
around chinatown and carrying guns
so they're also hurting people before
they're being robbed this is description
not of hate crimes but of out and out
lawlessness
this behavior seems obviously tied to
recent political hostility to the police
many cities have yielded to activist
demands that they slash police budgets
and cut public safety services bigotry
may have played a role in these offenses
but changing the hearts and minds of
bigots is far harder from a
policymaker's perspective
than preventing bigotry driven crimes if
anything
is to blame for the terror now plaguing
asian americans this public official's
dereliction of their duty to preserve
public safety
i urge the members of the committee to
advocate a restoration of public safety
by pushing back on anti-police rhetoric
by supporting more federal funding for
police
this is the best way to ensure that
asian americans and all americans
can again walk the streets free from the
fear of violent crime
thank you and i look forward to taking
your questions
thank you mr layman next witness is uh
with us here in person that's a nice
exception
nice to you to be here um mr wing kong
bah mr faw is an attorney with the
pacific legal foundation litigating
cases focused on free speech and
equality before the law
he receives jd from the university of
michigan
not in the ncaa tournament i think maybe
they are i don't know
and the masters they are in the
tournament aren't they yeah and a
master's degree in political philosophy
in the london school of economics and a
va from the university of texas dallas
mr fall you recognize for five minutes
sir
uh chairman ranking member thank you for
inviting me to testify today
uh before i begin i want to express my
uh
want to say that i'm saddened by the
violence committed in georgia on tuesday
i express my heartfelt condolences to
the families of the victims
i never could have imagined being here
today when i boarded a flight from
beijing to san francisco
25 years ago i knew two words of english
when i got to america
banana which i likely learned on the
plane
and goodbye which my grandmother taught
me in beijing as she dropped me off at
the bus stop
every sunday since then i became the
first person in my family
to receive a law degree and i won the
first case i litigated before the
supreme court
in june 2018. a few
hours after i got the decision in the
supreme court case
i went to take a citizenship test in
front of an immigration officer
and i laughed when he asked me how many
justices there were on the supreme court
i have since become a proud citizen of
the united states
i am here today to say that racial
discrimination is wrong
but when it comes to asian americans and
education
far too many in our government condone
discrimination
this is something i've experienced
firsthand as an attorney with the
pacific legal foundation
where my colleagues and i represent
asian american families who have felt
the sting of government sanctioned
discrimination
these families seek to vindicate the
principle of equality before the law
which requires government to treat
people as individuals
and forbids government from treating us
differently on the basis
of government-sanctioned stereotypes
last week pacific legal foundation filed
the case challenging fairfax county's
discriminatory changes
to its admissions policy for thomas
jefferson high school
or tj at as as it is more commonly known
we represent a coalition of parents
including dr
chen a chinese-american a chinese
immigrant who is now a chemistry
professor
his eldest daughter attends tj but
her younger sister might not get that
chance
that's because the county replaced an
objective test with a so-called holistic
process designed to racially balance the
student body
at the expense of asian american
students
the changes that tj were made against
the backdrop
of unfounded racial stereotypes one
school board member
referred to the culture at tj as toxic
a virginia state delegate accused asian
americans of being dishonest
in getting their children admitted and
made the baseless claim that the parents
had no intention
of staying in america we're pursuing a
similar case in montgomery county
where efforts to racially balance the
magnet middle schools
have drastically reduced the number of
asian american students
in yet another case i represent asian
american families in new york
my clients include asian american
immigrants who want the opportunity for
their children to earn their way
into public schools like stuyvesant
bronx science
and brooklyn tech but mayor de blasio
stated that the majority asian
compositions of those schools
was a quote monumental injustice and
changed the emissions policy to make it
harder for low-income
asian american students to get into
those schools
pacific legal foundation has also
followed the front of the court brief
in students for fair admissions versus
harvard a case using harvard's explicit
use of
race in a way that decreases asian
american enrollment
this too has led to pernicious
stereotypes including college guidebooks
telling asian
american students to refrain from saying
that they have
aspired to pursue a career in medicine
or major in math or science
apparently those interests are too asian
this is america
government should not condone
discrimination and it must not actively
engage in it
the subcommittee should continue to
explore ways in which official
government policy
has discriminated against asian
americans and continue
to work with pacific legal foundation
and others to end
this racial discrimination thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
for appearing in person and thank you
for keeping your mask up that's
appreciated by all of the
committee our next witness is mr daniel
day kim
mr kim is an actor and producer he's
best known for his role
as jinsu kwon on the tv series lost
which he shared a 20 2006 screen actors
guild award for best ensemble
he also portrayed chinho kelly on the
series hawaii 5-0
for seven seasons last month together
with actor daniel wu
he offered a 25 000 reward for
information regarding a january 31
assault of a 91 year old man
in oakland chinatown following two
similar incidents targeting
elderly asian residents mr kim received
a master of fine arts degree from new
york university
and his undergraduate degree from
haverford college mr kim
you're recognized for five minutes
thank you chairman cohen and uh ranking
member roy and the members of the
judiciary committee i'm both honored and
dismayed to be back in front of you
again
some of you may remember that i was with
you just this past september discussing
the importance of diversity in american
media
you may recall that the reason i was
moved to speak then
was because the house had just recently
passed h.r 908
condemning all forms of anti-asian
sentiment
but i was disheartened to find that for
a bill that required no money or
resources
just a simple condemnation of acts of
hate against people of asian descent
164 members of congress all republican
voted against it
and now here i am again because as every
witness in this hearing has pointed out
the situation has gotten worse much
worse
vichar atanapati murdered paco
murdered no quintana face slashed with a
blade from ear to ear
an 89 year old woman set on fire
tara taka ono a professional jazz
pianist beaten so badly he can no longer
play piano
and now seven asian people shot dead in
georgia two days ago six of whom were
women
these are only a few of the 3 800
reported incidents since last march
i was speaking to a pollster during the
recent elections and
i asked him why when i see polling
results broken down by race
do i so rarely see asian americans as a
separate category
he heard my question he looked me dead
in the eye and he said because
asian americans are considered
statistically insignificant
statistically insignificant now all of
you listening to me here by virtue of
your own elections are more familiar
with the intricacies of polling than i
am so
undoubtedly you already know what this
means statistically insignificant
literally means we don't matter
we as asian americans have come to this
country because we believe in the
american dream
many of us have succeeded and some of us
are even the front line health care
workers upon whom we've all
come to depend during this terrible
pandemic
but many of us are struggling too in
fact the wealth disparity between the
richest asian americans and the poorest
is the largest of any ethnic group in
america in new york
asian americans have a higher poverty
rate than any other minority group
where fully one in four are living below
the poverty line
and poverty rates among asian american
seniors are much higher than the
national average
that's something to consider as we watch
the most vulnerable in our community get
taunted pushed slashed and murdered
despite this wide disparity of
experiences we continue to be tagged
the model minority we simply cannot
continue to live with the myth that the
most successful of us
represent the totality of us
so we know the hurdles we face the
question for us here
is what can we do about them one of the
places that starts is with education
let's teach them everything that
professor lee so eloquently highlighted
for us
including celebrating the fact that the
most decorated combat unit in u.s
military history
was the 442nd combat team a unit in
world war
ii made up entirely of asian americans
now these are not moments in asian
american history this is american
history
when we are erased from our history
books we are made invisible
and the result to quote congresswoman
meng is that we are perpetually made to
feel like foreigners in our own country
include our stories because they matter
we must also empower our local community
organizers by directing funds to areas
that have been historically impoverished
not just for the benefit of the aapi
community but for the for the benefit of
all communities living there
most of whom are non-white it's no
wonder that there's historically been
tension among racial groups when the
thing they have most in common
is poverty and lack of access to
services
and there happened to be two pieces of
legislation before this committee as we
speak
that deal with these specific issues one
is the no hate bill
it provides necessary grants and money
to community organizations
counseling for those convicted of hate
crimes and improved data collection for
hate crime reporting among other
important services
the committee also has before right now
the clothing 19 hate crimes act
introduced by congresswoman mang and
senator hirono
it's crucial that we have reliable
reporting for these hate crimes and an
infrastructure that makes it easy for
people for whom english is not their
primary language
chairman adler you have been an ally to
the aapi community in the past
i respectfully urge you not to let these
bills languish in committee but
see them through so that they can be
passed by the full house and then on to
the senate
now i'm not naive enough to think that
i'm going to convince all of you to
stand up for us
trust me i've seen your voting records
but i am speaking to those
to whom humanity still matters
in closing let me just say that there
are several moments in a country's
history
that chart its course indelibly for the
future
for asian americans that moment is now
what happens right now and over the
course of the coming months
we'll send a message for generations to
come as to whether we matter
whether the country we call home chooses
to erase us
or include us dismiss us or respect us
invisibilize us or see us
because you may consider a statistically
insignificant now
but one more fact that has no
alternative is that we are the fastest
growing racial demographic in the
country
we are 23 million strong we are united
and we are waking up thank you
thank you sir thank you our next witness
is sheeran cenar
she's professor of law and john a wilson
faculty scholar at stanford law schools
her scholarship focuses on among other
things the role of institutions are
protecting individual rights and
democratic values in the national
security context her recent work
assesses the legal regime for domestic
and international terrorism under u.s
law
professor sonar holds a jd from stanford
uh a master of philosophies
international relations from cambridge
university and an m.a and a ba as well
from harvard
she was a law clerk for the honorable
warren g ferguson
warren j ferguson of the u.s court of
appeals for the 9th circuit
professor sonar you are now recognized
for five minutes
thank you for convening this important
hearing and inviting me to participate
i want to begin by acknowledging the
horrific mass shootings in atlanta
whatever the motive those murders have
traumatized
asian-american communities already
reeling from a year of persistent hate
violence
i'd like to make two points today first
while the causes of hate crimes are
complex
academic research shows that hostile
rhetoric from political leaders
towards immigrants or racial minorities
can embolden people to commit violence
against them
research also shows that political
events that change
perceptions of social norms like the
acceptability of racist
or xenophobic views have triggered hate
violence
and specifically with respect to former
president trump
prior studies have shown that hate
crimes spiked
immediately after his election and that
his negative tweets
towards muslims strongly correlated with
anti-muslim
hate crimes that brings us to the past
year
when former president trump and other
political leaders
relentlessly characterized the
coronavirus in racist terms
as recently as this week stop aapi hates
research
shows that donald trump's anti-asian
tweets
were shared on social media over a
million times
a substantial number of anti-asian hate
incidents
used language similar to trump's
beyond rhetoric the racial profiling of
chinese
and chinese-american researchers
scientists
and students as security risks exposes
asian-american communities
to a higher risk of societal
discrimination and violence
this is familiar from the experience of
south asian
muslim sikh and arab american
communities
treated as suspects over the nearly two
decade long
war on terror while hostile rhetoric or
discriminatory policy
is certainly not the sole cause of
recent asian
anti-asian violence it has made asian
americans
vulnerable both to racially motivated
and
to opportunistic attacks
the second point i'd like to make is
that while the response to hate crimes
is often built to call for increased
sentences many asian american community
organizations
are now advocating a broader set of
strategies
to address hate crimes horrific acts
like the atlanta shootings
require a serious law enforcement
response
but for several reasons community groups
are also looking for solutions
beyond criminal law especially with
respect to the more
common forms of hate crimes that occur
for one thing many incidents of hate
speech
targeting asian americans do not qualify
as
criminal but they still create
significant
harm in addition many victims
do not report incidents to police
because of mistrust of law enforcement
and concern around over-policing and
mass incarceration
has led many in communities of color to
consider other avenues to help victims
heal
hold perpetrators accountable and
prevent violence
numerous asian-american organizations
have emphasized
the importance of cross-racial
solidarity in response to hate crimes
rather than pitting struggling
communities against
one another many have advocated deep
investments in communities to strengthen
support systems both to prevent violence
and to support violence when hate crimes
occur
that support can take many forms whether
it is through funding
culturally competent mental health care
services
reforming victim compensation programs
to better support
hate crimes victims hosting conflict
de-escalation training or establishing
grant programs to protect institutions
at high risk of hate crimes
there is also growing interest in
exploring forms of restorative justice
to address hate crimes especially with
respect to young offenders
and relatively less serious offenses
restorative justice refers to processes
that bring together people
affected by an offense to address the
harm
and agree upon mechanisms to repair it
some evidence suggests that restorative
justice programs
reduce recidivism and alleviate the
emotional harm of survivors
better than traditional criminal
processes
they are not an option in every case and
much more research
is necessary but there is growing
interest within communities
in creative alternatives to hold people
accountable
help victims recover their sense of
safety
and prevent further violence thank you
for the opportunity to share these
thoughts
thank you for sharing thank you our last
witness
is hiroshi motu
mora he is susan westerman susan
westerberg
prager distinguished professor of law
faculty co-director
center for immigration of law and policy
at ucla
his teachings and scholarship focus on
immigration and citizenship his book
americans and waiting the lost story of
immigration and citizenship in the
united states
won the professional and scholarly
publishing award for the association of
american publishers as the year's best
book
in law and legal studies professor mo
chamura received his jd from cal
berkeley
and his ba from yale professor you're
now recognized for five minutes
mr chairman ranking member thank you for
the opportunity to speak to you today
my remarks take a step back from the
specifics of the incidents that other
witnesses addressed
there's a natural tendency to explain
away these crimes
as isolated acts of the few individuals
and related is a natural tendency to
avoid a deep look at why these crimes
are committed
why more crimes now why can't victims of
asian ancestry
but these crimes follow a long
historical pattern as you've heard today
and i'd like to explain a key reason for
this history
individuals commit crimes but they do so
in a society that reflects the laws
under which we live
to see hate crimes as isolated as to
close our eyes to the role of law
and shaping attitudes especially about
who's worthy
and who's not my focus is on the
immigration laws of the united states
especially how these laws have laid the
foundation for hate crimes against asian
americans in the past
in the present but i hope not in the
future
i'll start by observing that throughout
our nation's history
immigration laws and statutes
regulations and executive branch orders
have discriminated
and excluded on the basis of race
nationality
religion and ethnicity many examples
chinese exclusion as you've heard dates
back to the 1870s and 1880s but it was
the law of the land until 1943.
my own family was one of the very small
number of companies allowed to come to
america before 1965
when immigration from asia was severely
limited
similarly the large undocumented
population from mexico reflects an
immigration system
and historically has treated mexican
immigrants as disposable labor
and today offers too few legal
opportunities to work and live with
family
in this country most recently many
people have been
barred from the united states because
they come from certain majority muslim
or african countries now immigration
laws that their simplest separate
them quotes outside the border from us
also in quotes inside the border
and this may be why public figures have
felt free to disparage and insult people
from certain other countries
even when some of those same public
figures might never say the same thing
about u.s citizens to trace the family
roots to those very same places
but immigration laws don't just affect
people outside the united states
immigration laws can make it hard or
even impossible for some u.s citizens
without others to live in this country
in their united states with their
spouses and children and other close
relatives
in other words uh to make a family here
uh to make a life here
in this united states as a family
and this way immigration laws tell some
us citizens they're still foreigners
that they cannot fully partake of
american life if they trace their family
origins
to disabled parts of the world or if
they follow a disfavored faith
the message is that their citizenship
isn't as worthy
of respect as the citizenship of other
americans
the citizenship is devalued in these
ways
immigration laws enable discrimination
that's based on race
often against u.s citizens chinese
exclusion for example was rooted in the
idea
that people of chinese descent could not
become fully equal citizens of this
country
because they're not white 120
000 people of japanese ancestry most of
whom were us
citizens were incarcerated in relocation
camps during world war
ii this too was only possible because
they were seen as foreign
because of their race so especially when
this permission
to discriminate is embraced endorsed and
amplified by the
public figures what happens next should
come as no surprise
the message is that some u.s citizens
don't belong that they're really
foreigners
and that their lives and property aren't
worth as much
that message leads to hate crimes
against people cast by our american
immigration laws as fundamentally less
american
nothing crime is an isolated act we need
to take national responsibility for the
role of law
and what we're seeing today by
discriminating in ways that suggest some
u.s citizens don't belong here
our immigration laws have laid the
foundation for hate crimes
and as long as our laws continue to lay
this foundation
our entire country will suffer because
the promise of a shared citizenship
that can unite us all will remain
unfulfilled
thank you and thank you sir we
appreciate your attendance and your
participation in our hearing
we will now have enter a round of
questioning and
uh we will be under the five-minute rule
ourselves and i'll begin by
recognizing myself for a question
and i'd like to ask miss lee
is there empirical or historical
evidence supporting the claim that
leaders promoting stereotypes
or using rhetoric aimed at a particular
ethnic racial group
leads to increased levels of
discrimination or violence against that
group
are there historical examples of this
thank you chairman for that wonderful
question
and the answer is clearly yes there is
unfortunately a huge amount of
historical evidence
uh the record is very clear we've got
uh mayors of major cities we have
lawmakers in congress uh explaining
asian people in the crudest most racist
terms in 1876 in
san francisco mayor bryant uh
mayor of the time of that city gathered
a
mob of thousands of people uh in
downtown san francisco
and talked about the chinese immigration
question as one
that needed to be solved or
that if chinese immigration would
continue it would lead to the
downfall of american civilization and
of the white race in 1882 when congress
is introducing lawmakers introduced the
chinese exclusion act
some of the lawmakers including senator
miller of california
described chinese immigrants as a
degraded
and inferior race and a threat to
national
security they stole jobs from white
workers
they um were also
a danger to the public good
of the country and then during world war
ii our military leaders
uh were very explicit in their
descriptions
of japanese people japanese americans as
quote unquote an enemy race one of the
leaders of that was one of our military
officials lieutenant
general john l dewitt who was in charge
of making sure that uh japanese
americans
were forcibly removed and relocated from
the west coast thank you
thank you i think we have a miserable
history in this area and i appreciate
your hallucinating upon it and i now
like to yield the remainder of my time
to
the honorable ted lou congressman from
california
thank you chairman cohen for holding
this important hearing and uh for
allowing me to participate
asian americans have now experienced a
surge
in hate crimes hate incidents and
discrimination since the start of the
pandemic
and i want to explore some of the
reasons for that i was struck
uh professor motomura when um
your testimony stated that individuals
commit crimes
but they do so in a culture and a
society that reflects many
influences and professor sonar
in your testimony you talked about the
rhetoric being
employed can you discuss whether there's
a link between
the rhetoric being employed and the
increase in hate crimes against asian
americans
when politics
of uh former president donald trump use
racist dog whistles that are clearly
interpreted as an effort to blame
one community or one government and by
implication the community of people
who are thought to be associated with it
that affects the entire society and
stop aapi hates research shows
as well that those tweets from the prep
former president
were retreated over a million times so
once you have that norm setting at the
top
that normalizes stigmatizing
a particular community for hate it
does lead to ripple effects across
society at large
thank you very much i'd like to now
respond to the ranking republican member
today at the hearing
i previously certain active duty in the
united states air force
i'm very aware of who the bad guys are
and who our foreign enemies are
but this hearing is about americans
of asian descent who are being targeted
in the united states
it's not about policing speech i
certainly active duty so you can say
whatever you want on the first amendment
you can say racist stupid stuff if you
want
but i'm asking you to please stop using
racist terms like kung flu
or wuhan virus or other ethnic
identifiers and describing this virus
i am not a virus and when you say things
like that
it hurts the asian american community
whatever political points you think you
are scoring by using ethnic identifiers
and describing this virus you're harming
americans who happen to be of asian
descent
so please stop doing that
i yield back thank you representative
lou for your service to our country
and your service to our country today i
now
recognize uh
oh mr burgess owens is virtually with us
so mr burgess owens
um the ball is in your court five
minutes
yes thank you thank you so much
mr chairman i'm second hold tight
we've heard a lot today about the
alarming rise in violence against asian
americans
my heart goes out to the amazing asian
american community and all victims of
crime
no one should feel unsafe in their own
neighborhoods i'm concerned that there's
a culture of law disses that's become
pervasive and impacts every community
and we need to follow the facts
for example in 2008 surveyed by the san
francisco police department
studied 300 robberies and 85 percent of
the assault crimes the victims were
asian
the perpetrators were black americans
between 1980 and 2008 the
department of justice found that 84 of
white victims were killed by white
offenders
and 93 percent of black victims were
killed by black offenders
what does this tell us about the
possibility of a deeper more systemic
issue like the
deterioration of the family unit and the
negative impact is having on all
communities
in addition to the violence we're also
seeing institutional discrimination
against
asian americans and universities overall
the asian community has been very
successful academically
but has also been discriminated against
because it's a culture committed to
meritocracy
as someone who's growing up in the 1980s
i understand exactly what institutional
racism looks like
and using someone's race is a factor
against
admission to college is totally
un-american our colleges must end that
now
these issues are complicated and i hope
we can get to the bottom of the rise of
the law this is that no americans should
experience
no american experience and also the
institutional discrimination
against asian americans by our colleges
and university
our governor cannot condone or take part
in this type of racism
uh mr mr levin i do have a question um
as you state citizens in all communities
asian americans among them
have the right to live free from around
mr owens you asked a question of someone
i believe
who did you direct your question to mr
layman
sounds like
it seems we have a problem with our
system
can anybody hear me out there
yeah but nobody can hear it
so can we stop the the time
are we fixing it
is he muted maybe
but i don't think can get mr lou can you
hear me
mr layman are you can you hear me
well i guess now we know why they call
it webex
thanks for waiting we've let the host
know that you're here
testing is there any
anybody hear us
[Music]
dude
it's just swiftly and certainly enforce
law in these communities
can you hear me can people hear me
mr layman try to talk again yes i i can
hear you i'm sorry i didn't realize we
cut out
you're back on you cut out at the two
minute and 40 second mark if you can
rewind to there
oh yes i'm sorry i've been talking to
representative owens i'm not sure i
guess it did not come through
nobody could hear you you re-rounded
rewind to 240 and start over again
that's something a yale man should be
able to do
yes sir uh i don't i don't i don't know
do i need to review the question please
okay
repeat the question what okay what do we
need to do to end
these attacks that we're now seeing on
the rise of being perpetrated uh
against asian americans and and i would
say that other americans that are going
through the same issues at this point
oh yeah i i think that the most
important and most proximately effective
policy response
comes down to uh acting to
ensure safety in the communities and the
best tool that we have for that our
publicity is public safety enforcement
is the police on the streets
i agree with my co-panelists that we
want to combat bigotry in the hearts and
minds of
some americans but that's not the most
swift or certain way to reduce
violent crimes in our communities
affected policing is
okay thank you mr pagan uh is there a
way to achieve diversity and
institutions of higher learning without
considering race within the application
or administ uh
emissions progress prop conference
process
uh yes i think there are ways to achieve
diversity
without using race on college campuses i
think when we talk about diversity
it's a mistake just to think about it in
terms of racial diversity i think
a lot of universities aren't very
diverse in terms of different
ideologies different viewpoints
and i think we should be doing more to
ensure that students on
college campuses are hearing views from
all sides
um in terms of uh racial diversity
itself
uh you know i think there are certain
ways that uh were proffered by the
students for fair admissions in the
harvard case
uh harvard currently as it stands gives
preferences to
athletes to legacy admits to
big donors and also to children of uh
and i think reducing or eliminating
those preferences
uh would be able uh would lead to an
increase in
even racial diversity without ex without
using racial preferences good
thank you so much and i'm going to reel
back my time thank you so much
thank you representative owens i now
yield five minutes
to the honorable the distinguished
the renowned and the respected gentleman
from maryland mr raskin
thank you mr chairman um
anti-asian-american violence is
skyrocketing
we've seen a 150 surge in anti-asian
american hate crimes in major cities
including
an 81 year old woman being punched in
the face and lit on fire
outside her own home a 61 year old man
being slashed in the face with a box
cutter
on the subway in new york city a woman
being doused in the face
with a burning toxic chemical as she
took out
the trash at our home and a 15 year old
boy being hospitalized
after being attacked at school by a
bully assailant who claimed he had
coveted 19 because he was asian
the governor of maryland larry hogan
whose wife yumi is
korean-american um told me uh
in a phone conversation yesterday that
he uh and his wife and his daughter's
closest friends
have all been affected by the new wave
of hostility against the aapi
community governor hogan told me that
close family friends have been
assaulted in a convenience store
screamed at
by racists telling them to go back to
china and told that they did not want to
sit next to them on an airplane
because they were asian and had coveted
there's no free speech
defense to commission of violent
assaults on asian americans or anybody
else
and the bizarre invocation of free
speech in this context
is a dangerous and irrelevant
distraction from the violence
engulfing aapi communities across the
land
we've got korean-american and
japanese-american and
vietnamese-american constituents
who've been attacked by racist fanatics
screaming about the wuhan flu
so just consider the leaps of uh illogic
and fallacy which lead to this kind of
crime first you've got to blame
the covet 19 virus on the chinese
government or the chai comms as the
ranking member proudly
uh puts it an authoritarian government
which president trump
lavishly praised 37 different times in
the first three months of coven 19 for
its
excellent response then you've got to
blame the lethal recklessness of
president trump
who said covet 19 would magically
disappear by easter
and suggest that injecting bleach is a
miracle cure
and refused to develop any nationwide
plan to crush the virus
on the chinese government and on the
chinese people
then you've got to associate the alleged
policy errors of the chinese government
with the chinese people then you must
associate the chinese people
with chinese american citizens of the
united states then you must associate
chinese american citizens with korean
americans vietnamese americans and so on
then you must assume that
all of your misguided and fallacious
views justify
violent attacks on asian american
strangers and
all of these fallacies and lies are
built on assumptions of collective guilt
mass punishment
and vigilante justice that are
completely at odds with our
constitutional values so it's remarkable
to me that when we try to put a stop to
this deranged violence
we have colleagues who think it's
irrelevant or productive to defend
donald trump's totally unmolested first
amendment rights
to blame